so if you think I'm asked me on this one
and there are just two things I want to
say about it the first thing is when
you're doing it by T results okay and
yes I have better this informally but
just like it is for solving trig
identities or solving equation that kind
of thing you have you can be prescribed
to do a particular integral x t results
back because we're trying to see do you
want they're not all just fits together
do you know where this are detailed DX
comes from like how to get it back in
terms of team after you get in terms of
trig functions in terms of X right being
able to do that is kind of the important
skill then it turns back into all right
so now it's a a regular or algebraic
substitution and off you go okay so can
be prescribed there's the first thing I
want of it and so don't don't shortcut
this I highly advise against like doing
this part in your head and just kind of
cramming it in because there are so many
ways even myself I've experiences where
you can be almost right you can be all
this right but then you'll be off by
like it'll be root 3 instead a reply
also like that and short of which i'm
about to show you sure of going back and
differentiate d you're like what what
went wrong you might not even know
anything went wrong just looks like it
just works okay so doing this properly
will help you ensure you nail this slide
down like we know how critical this line
is and they've kind of everything
procedure them ok so I've mentioned that
secondly you get to this answer here ok
now it's tempting to look at that and
think okay there's our 10 inverse and
this tears can't I go further here
because sometimes we should I'm going to
see for instance you get out of partial
fractions you get to log things well
clearly an advantageous to combine them
into one can we do anything with this
that the answer is in simple terms with
the tools we've got in a reasonable
amount of time not really okay the
reason why is if we had something like
this
if you're telling us of temp whatever
right we've seen how to deal with this
and thankfully because of the way 10 is
it's got its 10 verse its domain is all
your backs and you know the range here
is over why so you can get something
nice here that will simplify up but it's
simply this coefficient here that
complicates things as we know it's not
just as simple as pie one on Route five
here I guess that means i can combine it
some way in here those are opposite
things i think this is going to be
whatever is happening in here is
adjusting the frequency yes and this is
it just see the efforts you okay so even
though those unconnected they are quite
distinct concepts okay so therefore
there's a lot of nice big way to just go
whoop and then put it in there to
convert it into something like this so
therefore you're basically done at this
point which may be you breathe a sigh of
relief you thank goodness I don't go any
further and you can prove to yourself as
I did like I've been doing this for a
while now and I still feel as though
integration by parts really feels like
magic right like you get to something
and you're like really like I once
you've done it read my part or use a
substitution like this yeah okay I
didn't really expect that but let's see
what happens and if you're careful with
it you make sure you don't screw up
chain rule right it just sort of comes
out beautifully in the washer like cool
you know it works ok so I'll recommend
every time you do either you raise my
parts or using a substitution like this
which ends up with something can't you
Twitter you can't be really CEO of
course oh it's true fight any of us want
to reply turn there too all right
anytime you see that just go ahead test
it's worthwhile just to flex your
differentiation muscles especially when
you look at this feel like do you see
how I have strong this together there's
at 205 became out the front what does
this part represent what's that that's
the derivative of the inside function
which has the 105 just hanging out there
can turns into sex square for there's
chain rule here so the half comes out
the front and then what's this what's
this part this is the derivative of
taylor verse which is one on one plus
whatever
Square and that whatever I have happens
to be that whole thing ok so I think
it's kind of nice to be able to see how
something that looks so disastrous it
comes back to something beautiful it
simple okay